how to balance the right of artists  against the needs of online users  Parliament wants to ensure the TU  copyright law protects creativity  without slowing technological progress  bacterial infections are increasingly  resistant to treatments members are  pushing for an integrated public health  approach fighting the misuse of  antibiotics and promoting education 3d  printing is a booming market now  accessible to the general public the  parliament is looking up ways to address  intellectual property and civil  liability issues members want to step up  the fight against terrorism cross-border  crime and irregular migration by  boosting law enforcement cooperation via  data sharing and alerts  [Music]